imagine you're a pro player playing
poorly and your boss calls you out live
on stream I don't know what
all right
so bang is a player for the hundred
Thieves valorant Team and in a recent
VCT America's match that nadjot watched
with Herrick well let's just say nade
got pretty intense
all the way back over towards Cassie has
his turn
plenty of people commented on his
reaction but nadeshot set everything
straight on Twitter and if we're being
honest everyone gets hype and intense
like this every once in a while and you
want your team to win even if they're
playing hopscotch in mid and I mean you
gotta remember nadeshot was a
professional Cod player at one point I
don't want to hear are you talking
if you're not gonna win the map